eines der größten ungelösten rätsel der
us musik ist das sogenannte hitze rätsel
warum ist die temperatur direkt an der
sonnenoberfläche geringer als in der
sogenannten corona also weiter entfernt
also der äußeren schicht ihre atmosphäre
jetzt kommt ein nasa forschungsteam nach
monatelanger arbeit diesen rätsel
vielleicht endlich auf die spur
denn sie hat an unerwarteten stellen
unglaublich heißen plasma regnen der
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen wie in aller
welt kann es sein dass es heißer wird je
weiter man sich von der sonnenoberfläche
weg bewegt unglaubliche temperaturen von
bis zu 5,6 millionen grad celsius können
in der korona in der äußeren schicht der
sonnen atmosphäre herrschen
auf ihrer oberfläche dagegen liegen die
temperaturen bei nur 5000 grad celsius
dieses rätsel ist bereits 70 jahre alt
und bringt forschungsteams weltweit um
den schlaf zwar wissen wir schon seit
längerer zeit dass es auf der sonne
regnet dieser solar plasma regen
befindet sich in gigantischen
magnetstreifen die eine million
kilometer über der sonnenoberfläche ins
all hinaus ragen es sind wirklich
riesige plasma ausbrüche in form eines
bogens und diese so genannten helm
ströme sind bei einer sonnenfinsternis
sogar von der erde aus zu sehen
genau in diesem gigantischen plasma
schleifen so dachten fachleute bislang
soll der plasma regen der sonne zu
finden sein seine entstehung erklärt
nasa forscherin emily mason
folgendermaßen im koronaren regen erlebt
heißes plasma hoch in der sonnenkorona
eine rapide abkühlung von rund einer
million kelvin auf 10.000 calvin
kondensiert und fällt zurück auf die
oberfläche so können diese art
wasserfälle ein unglaubliches sturz
tempo von 200.000 kilometer pro stunde
erreichen heißt also dass sich das
plasma am tiefsten punkt der
magnetstreifen an der sonnenoberfläche
auf etwa eine million grad erhitzt und
dann die magnet schleife herauf wandert
es entfernt sich von der hitzequelle
kühlt ab und kondensiert die gravitation
der sonne sorgt dafür dass das material
wieder zu ihr gezogen wird und so kommt
es zum solaren regen aufgrund der
bisherigen erkenntnisse zum plasma regen
hat das forschungsteam der nasa gezielt
in diesen gigantischen magnetstreifen
der sonnenoberfläche nach dem regen
gesucht ganze fünf monate lang hatten
sich die fachleute durch die große
datenmenge des solar dynamics
observatorien der nasa gekämpft doch
erfolglos dabei gehen doch alle
bisherigen modelle davon aus dass der
solare plasma regen in genau diesen
strukturen aus regte dazu emily mason
vielleicht ist der regen sonst so klein
dass werden nicht sehen wir wissen es
einfach nicht doch die fachleute gaben
nicht auf und wurden schließlich für
ihre geduld belohnt denn schließlich
fanden sie den plasma regen an einem
völlig unerwarteten ort und zwar in
deutlich kleineren plasma bögen die sich
in einer höhe von lediglich 50.000
kilometern erstrecken hier regnet es
sogar sehr reichlich dazu heißt es in
der aktuell veröffentlichten studie
die häufigkeit des regens und die
leichtigkeit mit der er dort beobachtet
werden kann sprechen dafür dass dieses
phänomen in topologien dieser
größenordnung generell vorkommt aus
dieser entdeckung schlussfolgern die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auch dass der solare plasma regen an
deutlich mehr stellen auf der sonne
vorkommt als bislang angenommen das
forschungsergebnis gibt zudem hinweise
auf das alte hitze rätsel der sonne denn
der regen kann nur entstehen wenn ein
großer temperaturunterschied zwischen
dem unteren und dem oberen bereich der
streife existiert heißt also im klartext
dass die aktuellen ergebnisse zumindest
den bereich eingrenzen indem die krone
erwärmt wird dazu emily mason wenn es
über der sonne regnet bedeutet das dass
das plasma in den unteren zehn prozent
der magnetstreifen extrem erhitzt wird
wir wissen immer noch nicht was genau
die korona so stark aufheizt es muss
aber in diesem bereich geschehen und das
nasa forschungsteam machte eine weitere
spannende entdeckung dass regen system
existiert nicht nur in geschlossenen
magnet schleifen sondern auch an offenen
magnet linien diese fragen ins all und
haben nur mit einem ende kontakt zur
oberfläche der sonne
die beobachtung interpretieren die
fachleute so dass der sonnen regen in
zusammenhang mit langsamen sonnenwind
stehen könnte demnach könnte sich das
plasma in einer geschlossenen magnet
schleife erhitzen und dann auf eine
offene linie über
ein teil des plasmas kühlt dabei ab und
regnet zur sonne herunter der andere
teil könnte ins weltweit gehen und somit
ein teil des sonnenwindes darstellen
doch dies ist bislang nur eine these
doch schon in den kommenden jahren
könnte die sonde park hat solar probe
zeigen ob die nasa fachleute mit dieser
vermutung recht behalten denn sie wird
so nah an die sonne heranfliegen wie
keine andere sonde zuvor die hauptfragen
die mit dieser mission endgültig geklärt
werden sollen wie entsteht der
sonnenwind und warum ist die korona der
sonne heißer als deren oberfläche
mysteriöses ufo an der sonne was ist das
neugier zone klärt euch auf draufklicken
anschauen und natürlich neugierig zone
abonnieren falls das noch nicht gemacht
habt bis dann bleibt dran